اسلحة الغرب فيها. اما الصين
فتغرد خارج السرب وتسعى لامتلاك
انباء عن انسحاب جزئي للقوات
الروسية من مناطق في الشمال
الاستخبارات البريطانية تقدم
القوات الروسية نحو سلوفيانسك.
الحديث بحسب وكالة رويترز فيما
لا يمكن اتهام الرئيس الكولومبي
وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
لافروف ان العقوبات الغربية رفعت
نقلا عن مصادر داخل مجال الطاقة
ان العقوبات التي فرضتها روسيا
على شركة فرعية المانية سابقة
تابعة لجازو بروم قد تكلف
العواقب الوخيمة للحرب بامر من
بوتين. ذكرت صحيفة الالمانية
الفترة من الخامس الى السابع عشر
من يونيو. الدفاع الروسية قوات
دومباز. تقول التقارير ان
الاعلان عن انطلاق مناورات
واكثر من خمس وسبعين طائرة ونحو
سبعة الاف جندي سيشاركون في
عسكرية لحلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو
في بحر البلطيق بمشاركة كل من
عاقبت محكمة كولومبية رئيس
البلاد فان دوكي بغرامة مالية
اسعار الطاقة وافادت روسيا
متوقعا زيادة كبيرة في عائدات
الرئيس اللبناني ميشيل عون قال
ان المفاوضات لترسيم حدود بلاده
غضب لبناني. في تطور خطير
للغاية. يقول سلاح البحرية
سيقوم بنقل نسخة بحرية من القبة
الحديدية الى المنطقة. وكان
عسكرية غربية فوق منطقة اوديسا.
زالنسكي يمكن للجيش الروسي وقف
حلف الناتو اوضح في له ان اربع
عشرة دولة من حلفاء الناتو
الدفاع الجوي اسقطت طائرة نقل
عسكرية اوكرانية محملة بمعد
السوري. تهديد بوتين حقيقي هذه
المرة والعاصمة كييف تشهد بتدمير
ردا على صواريخ جيرانه مع
امريكا. فهل تعود السكينة للعالم
المنطقة المتنازع عليها يشكل
استفزازا وعملا عدوانيا. بينما
التعدي على ثروات لبنان? الاحداث
والتطورات. بعد اجرته الصحيفة
قال رئيس حكومة تصريف الاعمال
نجيب ميقاتي ان تعدي اسرائيل على
الا من قبل البرلمان. يصر
اردوغان على ان تركيا ستنتقل الى
مرحلة في عملية تشكيل منطقة امنة
بعمق ثلاثين كيلو مترا على طول
واقامة جبرية لخمسة ايام وقدرت
الغرامة باربعة الاف دولار لعدم
والتحقيق معه الا من قبل لجنة
تشريعية خاصة ولا يمكن محاكمته
مدينة الاستراتيجية في الشرق حيث
يحتدم القتال. في وقت اكدت فيه
تصدير الطاقة. اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانية سيطرتها على نصف
المانيا حوالي خمسة مليارات يورو
من النفقات الاضافية سنويا. قال
خرجوا في مظاهرات غاضبة في عدة
مدن هندية منددين بالاسلاموفوبيا
تصريحات استراليا فهل يحتاج هذا
الموضوع ردا صينيا? غضب اسلامي.
الطائرة الاسترالية على العودة
الى القاعدة. يقول الاستراليون
نوبور شارما المتحدثة باسم حزب
بهارتيا جاناتا الحاكم في الهند
واثنتين من الدول الشركاء للناتو
واكثر من خمس واربعين سفينة
الاعلان مؤشر موافقة على
الانضمام رغم استمرار رفض الرئيس
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا زلنسكي يزور
اوكرانيا في جبهة قتال اقليم
حدودها الجنوبية والقيام بعملية
تطهير تل رفعت ومنبج في ظل تردد
الفضاء. ما عدت تتسع للصينيين
ومجنون كوريا يقيم حفلة صواريخ
الاسرائيلية انه يستعد لاحتمال
تعرض منصة الغاز كريش لهجوم وانه
صلى الله واله وسلم ما اثار
حفيظة المسلمين في الهند الذين
مدرعات فهم يستقلون سيارات
وشاحنات مدنية تتحول الى حطام
الجنود الاوكرانيين وان الجنود
الاوكران بدلا من ان يتنقلوا في
حمايته منتزها وطني في قرار نادر
وغير مسبوق في تاريخ البلاد
الدورة الحادية والخمسين من
التدريبات البحرية الرئيسية في
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
انضمامهما حتى تلبى شروطه. وكان
السويد وفنلندا الدولتين اللتين
تعرقل تركيا انضمامهما للحلف هذا
الجنود ان الاسلحة الغربية تباع
في السوق السوداء ولا تصل الى
ثروة لبنان المائية وفرض امر
واقع امر في منتهى الخطورة. فهل
على الاسرائيليين ان ينتظروا ردا
عسكريا من حزب الله اللبناني بعد
من الواضح ان هذا امر خطير
للغاية. بكين لم ترد بعد على
خلال ايام قليلة. في ثاني زيارة
له خارج العاصمة كييف منذ بدء
الكندية تورنتو ستار مع مقاتلين
كنديين عائدين من اوكرانيا كشف
نجاح هذه العملية يوضح تكثيف
الصين جهودها للسيطرة على
من الحكومة الهندية التعليقات
فهل تعتذر الهند للمسلمين كافة?
بحر الصين الجنوبي. ونفذت
الطائرة الصينية مناورات اجبرت
على العالم وازاحة امريكا من
القمة. ها هي بكين اليوم تطلق
التنديد بخطوة بيونج يانج مشددا
على انها تهدد السلامة
جانبها اليابان ابدت استيائها
حيث سارع رئيس وزرائها الى
الدول الاسلامية التوقيف لكنها
تتوقع اعتذارا علنيا رفضا رسميا
البحرية مع اسرائيل لا تزال
مستمرة وان اي عمل او نشاط في
عربية واسلامية ليعلن الحزب وقف
المتحدثة باسمه. بينما تقبلت
مركبة الفضاء شينتشو اربعة عشر
التي تعد السابعة من اجمالي احدى
على مناورات امريكية كورية
جنوبية مشتركة. والتي يعتبرها
منذ اكثر من اربعين يوما. بوتين
هدد بضرب اهداف جديدة اوكرانية
تصريحات له قال ان القوات الجوية
الروسية تكسر الاسلحة الامريكية
الذي يتزعمه رئيس الوزراء
ناريندا مودي اساءت للنبي محمد
الهندية. رافق ذلك شجب واستنكار
وتنديدات شديدة اللهجة من دول
مقاتلة صينية احدى طائرات
المراقبة البحرية الاسترالية فوق
الامريكي لكييف الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اكد ان الصواريخ
الامريكية التي ترسل للقوات لن
تغير شيئا على الارض. وفي
بسبب الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية
ووسط تدفق السلاح الغربي لا سيما
الفضاء. فالفضاء هو المستقبل
بنظر الصينيين. فماذا تركتم
لبقية العالم يا اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. خلال ذلك باغتت طائرة
كيم بمثابة استعداد لعملية غزو
فكان رده حازما هذه المرة. من
التي اطلقها الروس عليها مؤخرا
وسط مخاوف امريكية من استهداف
الروس للرئيس الاوكراني زلينسكي
او حكومته لاضعاف الجانب
واقع تصاعد التوتر بين روسيا
والولايات المتحدة الامريكية
والاسلامي. المجنون لا يتوقف
ويقدم وجبة رعب للجيران.
على التراجع بينما تستعد بكين
لاستكمال محطتها الفضائية. خطوة
روسيا والمانيا تتلقى الخسائر.
اليس هذا عجيبا؟ العالم ينتفض ضد
تصل لواشنطن? الصين الى الفضاء.
بينما تقترب الصين من السيطرة
غير مسبوق ورقم قياسي للصواريخ
المطلقة جاءت هذه الصواريخ ردا
والاستقرار في المنطقة. فهل وصلت
رسالة المجنون لجيرانه قبل ان
تطلق وابلا من الصواريخ على
سواحل جارتها الجنوبية. ووابل
عشرة مهمة لاستكمال المحطة
الفضائية بحلول نهاية العام.
لاوكرانيا. فهل تكون كييف
التالية بعد خصوصا بعد الصواريخ
لم نستخدمها من قبل. هكذا قالها
بوتين للامريكان فاما ان يتوقف
بعد كل هذه التوترات?
لقد طفح الكيل. سنسحق صواريخكم
واسلحتكم وسنستخدم اسلحة مدمرة
الاوكراني. رد المجنون. صواريخ
كيم تتساقط في سواحل الجنوبية
لم يطلها القصف من قبل اذا سلمت
امريكا صواريخ بعيدة المدى
استفزازية من للبنان هل تكون
سببا للحرب بينهما؟ وحكم غير
مسبوق على الرئيس الكولومبي
بالسجن. رد موسكو القاسي. على
صواريخ كروز روسية موقعا به
دبابات حصلت عليها اوكرانيا من
الدول الغربية هذا القصف
الصاروخي يطال كييف للمرة الاولى
الجديدة كحبات جوز وتتعامل معها
بسهولة. جاء ذلك بعد ان ضربت
عن امداد اوكرانيا بتلك الاسلحة
والا فالدمار مصيرها. فكيف سيرد
الاوكرانية وجنود كييف دون
اسلحة. العقوبات فرضها الغرب ضد
الامريكان هذه المرة. اسلحة
الغرب تباع في السوق السوداء
الهند الا رسول الله يا مودي.
هكذا يصرخ العالم العربي
واليابان تعلن استيائها. الصين
تعترض طائرة استرالية وتجبرها